hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday January 19th no genuine knife
sorry 2017 January 9th 2017 you know
that's how bad I am at math I can't even
[ __ ] say the date right um how's it
going how are you oh the summer wind
it came [ __ ] blowing in because of
global warming it's [ __ ] cold for
about two weeks and then it's hot my
[ __ ] house is gonna melt and then
it'll slip into the sea I don't give a
[ __ ] that it's snowing and Massachusetts
going what's going on it's already
getting hot as [ __ ] out here dude you
should be a meteorologist yeah it's
gonna be hotties [ __ ] [ __ ] Los
Angeles um how are you how's it going
you're out there you fighting the good
fight you're trying to be a better
person you're trying to turn around your
[ __ ] childhood well join the club had
a little setback yesterday you know Oh
[ __ ] new Billy was running around an
old Williams showed up yesterday I just
I you know whatever I just got to keep
[ __ ] you know moving forward you know
moving forward like the Celtics and the
Bruins okay we're not winning
championships this year but you know
we're trying alright I'm not going to
get rid of all of my anger in [ __ ]
two weeks but you know if you could just
chop away even a half a percent you'll
be a half a percent better today than
you were yesterday
you know Jesus Christ you know it what's
[ __ ] up is no one that you [ __ ] up
and then actually really analyzing
yourself and you're like whoa I didn't
know it was that deep um anyways so what
do you do what do you do when you know
you're [ __ ] up and you can't really
fix it in a day what do you do well you
know what you do is you [ __ ] crack
open a beer and you watch some god
am sports that's what you do to distract
yourself from all this [ __ ] that's going
on I love this whole [ __ ] story about
the Russians hacking into the [ __ ]
Democratic national [ __ ] convention
committee [ __ ] websites and all that
all these [ __ ] Hillary supporters
yeah that's why you [ __ ] Trump was
able to eke it out it's just like I
can't even [ __ ] I can't listen to any
and then you look at the Trump
supporters you like there what's the big
deal it's just the Russians the bottom
line is you either give a [ __ ]
or don't give a [ __ ] about what the
Russians allegedly did or didn't [ __ ]
do depending on whether you wear a blue
tie or a [ __ ] red tie and I love how
in the end of all this like I'm supposed
to listen to the [ __ ] CIA like they
don't have an agenda
everybody in this story has a [ __ ]
agenda so it's like who the [ __ ] do I
listen to you know good [ __ ] Lord you
think Obama would give a [ __ ] if the
hacking led to Hillary winning will
we'll do something when the time is
right and what level but why because the
lady with the blue bra lost what if she
won Obama won then what the [ __ ] would
you do you ride off into the sunset
getting ready to do your [ __ ]
speeches for [ __ ] 300 grand to clip
to the exact people that got you in the
White House it's all I can't that's why
I watch sports that's why I watch sports
because other than a couple of mobbed-up
reps here or there you know it's pretty
fair it's about as fair as it can get
which means it isn't fair so anyways um
I love that people don't like that Trump
is friends with Vladimir Putin have you
say scences Putin um Putin him you know
that that not being friends with the
Russians the first time didn't work out
too well with the whole thing almost
blew up in her face so you know why
don't we try to hold hands this time
I don't know I this is I don't get into
Paul's - I think war should be illegal I
think war is literally it's the temper
tantrum of the [ __ ] Illuminati and
then everybody else has to pay the
[ __ ] price you know and those rich
loafer wearing [ __ ] will never step one
foot into a battlefield you know they
all make the [ __ ] money off it's just
a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] and when are
they going to grow up I love how I can't
go over my fence and just take a bat out
and beat the [ __ ] out of my neighbor
because of I don't know whatever the
[ __ ] they did you know the apple trees
on their property and I want the apples
on my [ __ ] property and I can't just
[ __ ] try to force them to [ __ ]
give me their apples and when they don't
I can then just [ __ ] come up with an
ID and I was some sort of angle of
[ __ ] that I tell the rest of my
neighbours and I go over there and I
[ __ ] smash up his house and kill a
few people in it I don't why can't I
can't do that on a [ __ ] local level
but as a country countries can do that
to one another it's just [ __ ] beyond
me I can't sit down at a [ __ ] table
and hash it out give us the oil No just
sit there at the table for [ __ ] years
just doing different Reed's give us the
oil No
um all right there's my [ __ ] wingnut
[ __ ] conspiracy theory horseshit for
you right out of the gate so let's go
right back to bread and circus okay
bread and [ __ ] circus you guys
watching the playoff playoff [ __ ]
football games I'll tell you right now
the two luckiest teams in the NFL right
now the Seattle Seahawks and the New
England Patriots why you say because the
other two best remaining teams in both
conferences are going to play each other
next weekend you know while the Patriots
played the the the Houston Texans in the
Seattle Seahawks play the Atlanta
Falcons now I'm not trying to disrespect
the Texans or the Falcons but whose kid
knew if you Seattle
and you got the Cowboys the Packers and
the Falcons left which is the best game
for you which gives you the best chance
of moving on to the next round
wow those [ __ ] dirty Birds down there
in Atlanta yeah with the Real Housewives
and the down-low brothers and if in the
AFC I would much rather as a patriot fan
watch us play the Texans without Jay Jay
Hawks right playing a home game while
the Kansas City Chiefs and the
Pittsburgh Steelers beat the [ __ ] out of
each other you know
Cowboys and Green Bay are gonna
eliminate one of them right you know the
deal so rather than Seattle having to go
through [ __ ] Green Bay and Dallas
they only got to go through one of them
and the Patriots rather than having to
play the Steelers and the [ __ ] Chiefs
we only got to play one of them thank
Christ the way that worked out so both
of us if we play the game that we should
be [ __ ] that we know how to play should
easily not easily but we should make it
to the to the [ __ ] NFC AFC
championship game of the [ __ ]
Patriots had to buy so we're [ __ ]
we're wearing flip-flops to the AFC
championship game having said that I
have no idea who is going to win the
Super Bowl I like many people I think
were amazed at how easily the Packers
handled the New York Football Giants and
as a Patriots fan I did not enjoy that
outcome because I wanted the rematch
you know I said that [ __ ] for the
last five weeks I want to see I want to
fire one of the Patriots play the Giants
again I wanted to see if definitively if
the Giants just [ __ ] on us you know
for the trilogy or could we get some
revenge you know what I mean that that's
what I was looking forward to so you
know I also love Eli and I actually love
the Giants believe it or not as a
Patriots team I don't understand like as
much as those two losses were painful
what is there to hate they're a great
[ __ ] franchise they always have a
great [ __ ] defense and a couple of
tough years
but I wanted the rematch oh my god that
would have been huge [ __ ] ratings
although a rematch Patriots Seattle
could also be a good thing however how
many times we beaten the Steelers in the
playoffs playoffs we beat them up I
don't every [ __ ] significant goddamn
I don't know I've lost count this would
this be number four so you can't tell me
the Steelers aren't due and I don't know
[ __ ] about Kansas City other than people
tell me that they're really good so it's
not going to be an easy AFC championship
game and if you're asking me if I'm
looking past the Dallas Texans I kind of
am but only as a fan I don't play for
the New England Patriots so I think the
Patriots will be fine that I'm kind of
looking past that the Houston Texans
going into New England without Jay Jay
ha um how about that [ __ ] catch by
Richardson you probably should say which
one but that one in the [ __ ] endzone
that was like one of the best catches
I've seen since Odell Beckham's you know
it wasn't anywhere near as good as that
but Jesus Christ [ __ ] Lillee reaching
around below the guy you know around his
junk past his taint they throw a flag
for an interception you still [ __ ]
catch it how many [ __ ] times is there
a flag in the end zone and the offensive
team gets to deny it because the [ __ ]
wide receiver reached around you know
that sounds [ __ ] perverted but yeah
around the defender you know why because
I stopped it reacharound reacharound
Jack reach-around [ __ ] reached around
the defender they probably teach you
that in broadcasting school you know and
one of the the main things you have to
look out for other than staying away
from advocacy of domestic violence
against women is when you're going to
use the expression that the the wide
receiver reached around the defender you
got to get you can't pause after a round
you got to go right to defend and reach
around the defender and then continue
with your idea anyway sorry so
a lot of people thought so most playoff
games were boring I know I did the
Steelers dolphins funny that was a
[ __ ] snooze fest but it's it's the
early routes it's the early rounds
everybody's evenly matched I think next
week's will be Weber group will be great
we'll see what the [ __ ] happens who do
you like who do you like I think a lot
of people are on Seattle's [ __ ] uh
beak as they say right everybody's
[ __ ] looking at them like oh well you
know they were just there and uh they
played pretty good against the [ __ ]
lights you know with a Green Bay Green
Bay's been there and everybody's like oh
you know [ __ ] all of a sudden here we
go Aaron [ __ ] Rogers looking like a
beast in the second half right and then
there's other people go [ __ ] Cowboys
that's why I don't [ __ ] watch pre or
post game analysis and probably why you
got well actually maybe you shouldn't
fast-forward through this because I'll
honestly tell you I don't know what the
[ __ ] is gonna happen I have no idea I
don't know what happens I haven't
watched Kansas City all year I just know
that uh what the [ __ ] is Andy Reid is
their coach and the last time I watched
them was the first time I saw him in a
red jacket and he looked like a big
[ __ ] tomato and I said you know what
I'm done with this franchise and the
only other time I paid attention to it
was when Paul virzi kept telling me that
us trading Matt Cassel or letting him go
to the Chiefs was a huge [ __ ] mistake
and do you think he ever apologized for
me to me for making that sort of a
comment I don't think he did I don't
think he did anyway so I'm continuing to
try to do the impossible which is watch
every home game of the Boston Celtics
and the Boston Bruins while sustaining a
healthy marriage it's not easy you know
what makes it really [ __ ] hard is the
Spruance and Celtics a lot of times play
on the same day and I for some reason
never think but why don't you just watch
one of them and then watch the other one
on the off day that's what I have to do
but I watched um you know I watched the
the CELTA I guess I taped the Pelican
game so I watched the Celtics beat the
pelicans and then I
watch the Bruins [ __ ] play the goddamn
Hartford Whalers via North Carolina and
every time we play the [ __ ]
Hurricanes it always goes in the lap we
played him three times in the last month
it always goes into overtime and we
usually we usually lose to those [ __ ] I
don't know what it was we used to own
the Hartford Whalers but ever once they
become the [ __ ] Carolina Hurricanes
we always lose to him
that reminded me of what used to happen
when the Patriots would go into Denver
we always lost you know granted they had
Craig Morton and then into John Elway
what do we have we had Tony Eason we had
Steve Grogan we couldn't match up the
Orange Crush defense and then John Elway
was better than him sorry we gave was
better than Tony Eason and but he wasn't
still on the draft board and I know what
you think we should have picked Dan
Marino well you know we didn't like
everybody else we [ __ ] didn't and you
know who paid the price more than
anybody else dan Marino because he went
to [ __ ] Miami and they never got him
a running game or a defense to this day
people [ __ ] trash him saying he
couldn't win the [ __ ] big one and
meanwhile they had to change every
possible [ __ ] rule in passing and
tippet so totally forward to the [ __ ]
the scales to the offense for Dan
Marino's records to finally start
falling yeah I'm a big damn Marino fan
anyways plowing ahead here and I've been
watching the Celtics just having a great
[ __ ] time watching both of them the
Bruins you know they hanging in there we
were out of the playoffs for a game
playoffs then we won I don't know the
[ __ ] we'd be watching so many [ __ ]
games we'd be Buffalo twice and then we
[ __ ] lost to Edmonton and then we'd
beat somebody and then we [ __ ] lost
in overtime to still the [ __ ]
Hurricanes I believe I don't know it
gets crazy to try to watch 162 [ __ ]
games anyways they're both [ __ ] them
we play the blues and then the [ __ ]
Celtics got a huge game against the
Toronto Raptors now if you're not
watching the Celtics of Boston this is
all you need to know I'm going to read
you their wins and losses and
you tell me if you can [ __ ] pick up
what's going on we'll go back to them
beating they beat the alright here we go
December 16th we beat the SH we beat the
[ __ ] that's a the Hornets one of the
Hornets stop being the Bobcats the
Hornets moved in New Orleans then they
became the pelicans and then that name
freed up and then the Bobcats like all
right is really you know not enough
Bobcats out here in North Carolina can
we go back to Hornets cuz them
[ __ ] are everywhere my overalls
and shoo fly North Carolina alright then
we beat the Miami Heat then we beat the
Memphis Grizzlies then we beat the
[ __ ] Indiana Pacers then we played the
Oklahoma City Thunder and we lost then
we played the Knicks we beat him then we
played the Grizzlies we beat him then we
played the Cavaliers and we lost you see
in a pattern here
that we beat the heat then we beat the
Jazz then we beat the Sixers then we
beat the [ __ ] pelicans and then
Tuesday
we're playing the Toronto Raptors so if
you look we [ __ ] we beat all the
[ __ ] regular Joe teams lunch-pail
larry's but we can't beat the Cavs we're
not beat [ __ ] OKC and now we got
[ __ ] uh we got Toronto so I don't
know I'll be very excited if we [ __ ]
um I'll be very excited if we [ __ ]
win that game because we haven't really
beat a contender yet since I've started
to watching them but anyways they're
saying if Celtics are like one [ __ ]
player away they're not one player way
if you really watch the Cavaliers and
you watch the Golden State Warriors
we're at least two [ __ ] players away
the fact that they want to move like
[ __ ] Marcus smart a [ __ ] Jae
Crowder for that white kid who used to
play at Butler for Brad Stevens you know
I'll tell you right now I'm reverse
racist when it comes to [ __ ]
basketball to do it we're going to trade
a black guy and draft picks for a white
guy who plays in Utah
I don't know first he's telling me the
guy's a beast
whatever the Hawthorne is some [ __ ] like
that I don't know [ __ ] about hoop I just
started watching I'm like a [ __ ]
housewife that finally got her Celtic
apron and stop making ham hocks and
speaking into the living room so I don't
have no idea what I'm talking about all
I can tell you is that I'm loving
watching the games dude the pelicans got
a great [ __ ] announcer - I was so
pissed because I love listen to Tommy
Heinsohn and the other [ __ ] guy who I
don't know his goddamn name I should
he's been doing the Celtics games
forever but the pelting the that would
see that that was that the pelicans and
the Celtics the pelicans are the peltex
they actually combined during World War
two
they played the steagle 's um they got a
great announcer old-school [ __ ] uh I
don't know he had a lot of elements of
Vin Scully I thought he was a class act
you could tell he was rootin for the
pelicans but he gave you know when his
team committed files he said all right
that's a foul you know he wasn't a total
Homer I like guys like that and I also
like total homers like Tommy Heinsohn
all right I'm gonna talk stop talking
about [ __ ] bats poker that's about as
deep as I go let me read a couple of uh
a couple of advertisements here all set
back Billy you know I thought I came out
of the [ __ ] clouds right okay Dollar
Shave Club everybody oh jesus here we go
Dollar Shave Club gives you a close
smooth shave and you can't beat the
convenience or the price
what does convey all convenient as they
bring it to you there's nothing
convenient about shaving it [ __ ]
sucks when you a kid all you want to do
you be get old and [ __ ] shave it's
the [ __ ] worst
it's so ridiculous man that you didn't
you didn't have to shave for like the
first [ __ ] I don't know 13 14 or 10
if you're one of those [ __ ] hairy
people years of your life you want at
least a goddamn decade 12 years without
having to [ __ ] shave although you
never know today with all the horse
tranquilizers that they put in their
[ __ ] food you've seen kids today you
know I mean there'll be like some fourth
grade boy with a beard talking to some
[ __ ] fourth grade girls who's
beginning to have titties you don't be
there like 9 or 10 years old you just
looking up without those [ __ ] those
little people know they've just brink
just been drinking the milk from the
cows that have been fed of the cows and
that's the result that make it little
[ __ ] adults you don't have to choose
between settling for a cheap bag of
disposables of paying out those up the
nose for raises with a laser pointer and
17 blades awful then Dollar Shave Club
broke onto the scene with a smarter
choice before Dollar Shave Club there
was no middle ground
it was either save money and get a
painful shape from a disposables like
the ones they give away for free at the
gym which felt like shaving with a piece
of glass I will tell you going from one
blade the two blade was great everything
else three four five has all been
[ __ ] complete [ __ ] two blades is
the perfect one that's the one you want
the third blade one became too thick and
you can't get under your cute little
button nose to shave there so you got to
start [ __ ] grabbing and pushing it up
giving yourself a pug nose like that
completes [ __ ] psycho
Orange County wife when are they going
to retire those [ __ ] brats my every
Denton is I could they're like on season
98 I walked by the TV and I'm like that
[ __ ] lady's still here she hasn't
gone to the community bin her [ __ ]
nose looks like that it's like the
Lincoln and the [ __ ] what's that
other tunnel in New York have I did I
move away that long wasn't the Hawthorne
the Holland Brook what's the one down
there by [ __ ] uh De Niro's restaurant
the Holland Tunnel Jesus
I guess that jokes over you can say your
[ __ ] nose looks like the Lincoln and
Holland Tunnel but you know when you
can't remember the other name of the
tunnel bill can you just complete the
read okay Dollar Shave Club is the best
of both worlds you get premium shape the
thishe Premium shape quality at the
disposable shaped price if you haven't
tried Dollar Shave Club yet you're
missing out it's an amazing shave at an
affordable price
there's no smarter choice in the market
and right now they're giving away a
one-month trial of any of their razors
for only a dollar with free shipping and
that's and after that it's just a few
bucks a month
Jesus [ __ ] Christ can you just give
him the website there's no long term
commitments no hidden fees and he can
cancel whenever you want get you $1 your
$1 trial at dollarshaveclub.com / /
that's dollarshaveclub.com / / i really
don't feel like [ __ ] reading these
this week how many of these for [ __ ]
[ __ ] sakes I can never be president I
could never sit there and read the whole
speech I couldn't do it I'd be like guys
can we can you cut this down you know
ask not what your country can do but you
[ __ ] figure out the rest all right
Alex Hilux you're unique you don't walk
like everyone else talk like everyone
else or sleep like everyone else so why
is your mattress one size fits all
because a truly customized mattress will
cost you five to ten thousand bucks
until now is that true go to HELOCs com
answer a few simple questions and
they'll run a 3d biomechanical model of
your body creepy people [ __ ] robots
robots [ __ ] people
moto modal model of your body through
the proprietorial algorithms they
developed with the help of the world's
leading leading arrogant allows and
biomechanic experts well there's a bunch
of big words there must be a comfortable
mattress the result the most comfortable
mattress you've ever slept on there you
go Hilux customers report a 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality
well how the [ __ ] would you know you're
asleep yeah but my dreams are so much
nicer and for couples okay now they're
getting oh geez think porno music now
they customized each side of the
mattress is there a side of the mattress
that muffles your partner's snoring your
mattress arrives at your door in about a
week and shipping is 100% free
that's why everyone from GQ magazine to
Forbes are all talking about helix sleep
you have 100 nights to try it out and if
you don't love it they'll pick it up for
free gross and give it give you a
hundred percent refund no questions
asked
oh my god that's disgusting go to helix
sleep calm slash burn get $50 off your
order
that's helix sleep calm / / helix sleep
calm / / oh here we go but oh boo boo be
on DS me undies [ __ ] on a [ __ ]
mattress do do do do me undies me undies
three weeks later you give it back to us
to those [ __ ] creepy [ __ ] they show
up with hazmat suits and a couple of
bunt [ __ ] cakes I don't know what I'm
singing about but your balls will feel
nice and velvety on your new mattress
maybe you shave your balls with Dollar
Shave Club all right picture a world
we're putting on a new pair of underwear
isn't just fresh you're stepping into a
better day think about it underwear it's
the first thing you put on the last
thing you take off why would you settle
for anything less than the best feeling
underwear on the planet maybe because
you're satisfied I don't know maybe
because I don't think about it please
include all of the following points
during your read me on DS focuses solely
on producing the most comfortable
underwear you've ever experienced
Vladimir Putin wears him he wears him
when he cax into the Democratic national
[ __ ] convention and you know what if
Hillary had been wearing him maybe she
would have won the election you know I
was watching a little bit of the Golden
Globes last night Jimmy Fallon made a
joke about the popular vote versus the
electoral vote you know it's so funny
watching all these liberals having a
problem with that [ __ ] like why do
you have a problem with it because you
think it's [ __ ] up or because your
person lost I can't [ __ ] like
literally watching that politic [ __ ]
it's like it's like watching Yankees Red
Sox my friends at me undies sent me a
few pairs a while back and now I can't
imagine wearing anything else well I
can't imagine where I can you know I
have a hell of an imagination
it really makes each day that much
better for the price of two cocktails me
undies will deliver your new favorite
pair of underwear right to your doorstep
better day guaranteed try them on and if
they aren't the most comfortable best
feeling undies you've ever had they'll
refund you and let you keep your first
pair for a free included in the price is
the sweet touch of modal Motel a special
fabric made with the best-in-class
materials that are scientifically proven
scientifically proven to be three times
softer than cotton and you can believe
that because mo
we'll paid for those [ __ ] research
scientific experiments I don't [ __ ]
these uber cozy undies are sold
exclusively on the Mian DS website where
you'll enjoy free shipping in the US and
Canada and for a limited time everyone
in my audience gets 20% off their first
order but you have to go to our special
URL me undies dot-com / / with the me
undies better day guarantee you have
nothing to lose so don't wait any longer
go to me undies calm / for right now for
20% off your first order
that's my undies calm / / hey you know
what somebody came up to me the other
day Badou doo doo doo and they go hey
did you see that story about the pit
bull these people this family tried to
put a Christmas sweater on the pit bull
and it [ __ ] just snapped and mauled
this woman and you know what I said I
said hey did you hear about the cocker
spaniel that bit that little girl's ear
off and then the person goes no I didn't
and I said of course you didn't it is
they don't report on it all the other
[ __ ] first so I look up this whole pit
bull thing is once in all people just
going these pit bulls man they're crazy
they're licking your face and and they
love their owner and then one day they
just kill him in their sleep all this
[ __ ] I looked it up okay two things
one the dog's name was Scarface repeat
the dog's name was Scarface number two
they lived in Florida okay can we quit
blaming the [ __ ] breed here jesus
[ __ ] christ that poor [ __ ] dog I
can't imagine the abuse that that dog
went through the dogs named Scarface
what kind of dog you think they wanted
it to be what do you think they trained
it to be that's what the [ __ ] they did
do you know when I was a kid we had a
west highland white terrier okay and me
and my brothers teased the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of that dog and it bit us routinely
bit me in the face one time and I almost
lost my eye you know why because we were
horrible to the dog that's why okay if
you get a pitbull and you name it
[ __ ] Scarface and you start feeding
it [ __ ] raw meat and making it at
action
eventually you know when you I guarantee
you they abuse the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
that thing
and what happened is when you put a
sweater on a dog at some point its head
is underneath the [ __ ] material and
it probably flipped out and then what
happens is you've abused the dog and
rather than it being a little west
highland terrier that you can push off
your [ __ ] face you've done it to a
dog that is in a way class that you
cannot [ __ ] handle but then what
happens is is they blame the dog because
human beings are so [ __ ] precious and
[ __ ] make no goddamn mistakes it's
it's it's [ __ ] ridiculous that they
keep blaming those [ __ ] dogs and I
know you guys would think we'll bill
didn't you just give away your pit bull
yes I did
because I understood that I didn't have
the capabilities as a [ __ ] owner
because of the abuse that happened to my
dog you know my dog when I first got it
I picked up a hockey stick the [ __ ]
stick handle in my living room and it
ran to the other side of the room and
started shaking uncontrollably okay I
don't know what the other people did
that but you know when you do that to a
[ __ ] dog you know I don't know I
still love pit bulls and I hate that
people come up to me with those [ __ ]
stories I don't give a [ __ ] you know
dogs bite people all the [ __ ] time
all these different breeds bite people
all the [ __ ] time every day a dog
bites somebody you're bringing a [ __ ]
animal into the [ __ ] house okay and
if you're not a good owner and you don't
know what the [ __ ] you're doing
you could get bent you get a hamster
you're gonna get bit you get a pet snake
you got to get bit you're bringing a
[ __ ] animal into the house my whole
[ __ ] life pit bulls were biting
people but it didn't get brought up
until somewhere in the 90s when I was
growing up it was one German Shepherd
one Doberman Pinscher after a [ __ ]
other you know
meanwhile Dalmatians are out of their
[ __ ] mind cuz they're purebred yet I
you know I don't know alright let's
let's get back to the [ __ ] podcast I
just I don't I don't buy into it the
same way I don't buy into the fact that
there's people in other countries you
know just sitting there more evil than
what the [ __ ] is down the street from me
we're all [ __ ] human beings some of
us are good most of us are [ __ ] you
know
I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about at this point alright let's
continue on let's continue on with the
podcast here as you might have guessed
at this point still no baby so we're
still [ __ ] waiting we are still
waiting on pins and needles and I am
getting to the [ __ ] point where it's
just like it's it's like enough already
this is just lie it's like waiting to go
on stage in front of a rowdy crowd you
just want to be like can you just bring
me up already so I can [ __ ] get this
over with
oh my god and I'm become I've become an
expert at talking people out of the
vortex of them give me giving me advice
about what to do on the day because they
just start telling me their stories and
then I'll just be like hey did you see
that [ __ ] nor'easter they just had
Becky I've got family back east and I
just I waltz them out of the
conversation because I tried being blunt
with people being like listen listen
listen
ay-ay-ay-ay-ay I don't care I don't want
to hear your [ __ ] story your [ __ ]
story is not going to help me your story
is all about you and you're just talking
about yourself and everything that you
learned I don't give a [ __ ] I've talked
to a thousand [ __ ] people it seems
like and every one of you tells me a
different story and a different thing
for me to expect which makes me feel
like every [ __ ] things a little bit
different so for the love of God can you
please shut the [ __ ] up can you please
stop with the verbal home videos uh I
can't wait to be a dad and not tell
other people how to be a dad
that is my goal as a parent I probably
won't do it I'll probably [ __ ] follow
the herd right over the cliff and be
like you know what you got it though
tell you right now look out for this you
know do you know this person told me the
other day that [ __ ] I would never
play drums again the second my kids
bored can you [ __ ] believe how
ridiculous that is yeah you won't be
playing drums anymore oh really well you
know [ __ ]
Dave Grohl plays drums he plays guitar
too and he sings in a band while touring
the world as far as what I've read he's
got a couple of kids I think he's doing
fine John Bonham had a kid when he was
[ __ ] 19 his band didn't even make it
yet he had a [ __ ] kid before his band
made it he was a teen dad before MTV and
he went on to become arguably the
greatest rock and roll drummer of all
[ __ ] time you know what I think old
freckles can sneak in a couple of
paradiddles what do you think you don't
really think about parents I think that
there's certain people that know how to
be a parent and not lose themselves in
it and actually still have a balance in
their life where they they have a card
game every once in a while obviously
your life is has to adjust but these
[ __ ] people that just like they just
they have no life and they just sit
there staring at their children you know
honey honey honey don't touch no no no
no no no they never let their kids fall
down they don't let them [ __ ] do
everything they just sit there like a
[ __ ] penguin with that goddamn egg
underneath them except the kids already
bored I don't think I don't know I don't
want to do that I don't want that to be
my life you know what I mean I think if
a kid is inside considering that we were
cavemen and we used to have babies they
were in caves and at any point a
saber-toothed tiger can come in and
[ __ ] just take the kid from you and
then that's it the fact that you're
[ __ ] inside with with [ __ ] central
air heating and food you don't have to
hunt you can go right down the street go
to the grocery store I know I'm
oversimplifying this but I have I have
to be honest with you when I talk to
other parents all they do is just give
me anxiety I'm so excited for this thing
to happen and then I talked to people
that have kids and they they they just
dump all this anxiety on you and I swear
to god I might be reading into this but
there's like a certain like 30% of them
that take like a certain perverted joy
in making you feel not feel well about
this experience that's allegedly the
greatest experience you're going to have
like they actually take this perverse
joy and I think that those people are
actually bad parents because I think I'm
totally guessing here I think that they
resent their children and what they took
from them and they still wanted to do
blow and go around and [ __ ] have
random sex with people and their state
never quite got passed they didn't quite
[ __ ] enough broads or jump on enough
dicks I don't know what it is but I
found it equally with men and women like
30% of them will take a perverse joy in
trying to infuse some sort of like
pre-emptive misery into your [ __ ]
life because I can tell you this right
now I'm still gonna play [ __ ] drums I
have to because if I don't I will go out
of my [ __ ] mind I'm not saying I'm
gonna play as much as I play but to sit
there and if you [ __ ] think that I'm
gonna sit here with a 71 green Sparkle
[ __ ] Ludwig drawn pit and I'm not
going to keep [ __ ] playing this thing
you know those people who out they who
play an instrument okay but you don't
make a living off of it you stop playing
it because you have a kid do you ever
think about maybe you know just playing
the instrument in front of your kid and
maybe that they'll take to it or maybe
they'll play in an instrument that they
could play and you together you could
have your own little [ __ ] you know
good time together bonding through but I
don't know the wonder of having music is
a [ __ ] hobby who are you hurting tell
you right now you better play that
ukulele cuz what's that kid clubs you're
never gonna play to me what is this kid
like some little Donald Trump and he's
gonna fire me as a dad if I continue to
do my little rudiments on my practice
pad how about I watch less TV in the
amount of time I spent watching all the
Bruins and Celtics why don't I take that
out of my life and then put that towards
watching the kid and then continue to
play drums I mean this is just much you
can make right
oh [ __ ] I got to tell you the story I uh
I always look at houses you know I'm not
gonna sell my house I love this [ __ ]
place as much as I [ __ ] that's why I
[ __ ] about it cuz I love this [ __ ]
house and and I'm gonna continue to
[ __ ] repair it then I'm gonna do the
[ __ ] homeowner 360 and when I have
the whole thing fixed I'm gonna start
over again in the first job because it
now it's going to be [ __ ] up whatever
I repaired at that point will then be
[ __ ] up so anyways I there was his
house for sale and I went to ghost I
went to go see it and it basically had
everything that you could ever want
right a beautiful house you know from
the outside was a beautiful house had a
[ __ ] pool had garage detached from
the house with a room above it which to
me is like oh there you go
I got the kid I got the house with the I
got the garage with the [ __ ] room
above it I put my drums up there turning
into a drum room slash podcast room
there you go that is my [ __ ] dream so
I go over to go look at this [ __ ]
place right knowing full well I'm not
gonna [ __ ] buy it because I can tell
at this point having bought a [ __ ]
house that needed all the work it does
but as as I'm driving up to it I can
already see the [ __ ] windows need to
be replaced and it needs a new roof even
though they told me you know we checked
out the roof then we had some inspectors
they said it's fine
oh yeah is that what they said why are
all these water stains all over the side
of the [ __ ] house what's that about
I like how the windows don't [ __ ]
quite they're not flush look at that
look at the rot around all of those
[ __ ] windows this house I can tell
you right now is already a borderline
teardown and I haven't even gotten into
it yet so I walk into this [ __ ] house
and holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] [ __ ] dude I I
took a tour this house there was three
separate times that I thought I was
going to get murdered alright first of
all we go to look at the room above the
garage first and there's just this this
moss growing on the side of the house
which I don't know if it was mold or if
it was Moss it was [ __ ] green and
the guy trying to sell it hissed you
know he's doing his best going you know
it's a mother-in-law suite he can
[ __ ] do this you can do that there's
room to add a little more under the
garage and I just point to the I'm like
what is that because yeah you know you
need me definitely needs a little bit of
work and so I go into the house and this
is random guy living there who isn't the
owner as a pole ponytail it's sparsely
furnished it was made in the 1920s so
it's already like creepy you can already
feel how many people have lived there
and are now dead and we just walk around
the house it got remodeled sometime in
the 90s yet it still had the [ __ ] you
know long Chaney jr. vibe of it from the
20s and I go downstairs it was like a
basement which they just don't have out
here and uh the guys like he can make
this into a TV room and there was all
like these [ __ ] files and film and
all this [ __ ] down there and like you
know that was the first time I was
thinking about like saw or the Blair
Witch I'm like alright can we go back
upstairs so we go back upstairs we go
all the way upstairs there was this
random like teenage girl living there
that was the daughter of the dude
downstairs who wasn't [ __ ] who lives
there but I don't know it's not his
house and we look up there and this is
stuffy [ __ ] smell and then as we go
down to go to the master bedroom they
said all the owner is the owners just
let you know the owner is there he's in
the house which usually they [ __ ]
leave there's all these people just
there this [ __ ] cat just sitting
there looking at me and I do the after
you to go to the master bedroom and he
does the after you to me and then I did
want to be rude so now I'm walking
towards the master bedroom down this
creepy [ __ ] Transylvania Hall with
the glove with the [ __ ] the guy
smiley real estate agent behind me who
you know he's though I'm sitting there
going like he's regular looking
good-looking guy that was to make me
feel safe and now I'm [ __ ] and I'm
walking towards this [ __ ] door and I
open the [ __ ] door
and I look in there and I swear to god
this is guy with like gray skin totally
[ __ ] bald like the landing strip and
then like you know like the little
[ __ ] uh mr. Whipple [ __ ] hair
around the side that he sort of died at
some point but now it was like this gray
he was totally gray you can see the
veins on the side of his head like Clint
Eastwood but not like I wouldn't want to
fight Clint Eastwood more like did this
guy die and then come back and he was
sitting down hunched down I think he was
typing on the side of his bed the place
was a mess he just sort of looked over
me innocently a he looked like the
[ __ ] dad in the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre and I was just like what the
[ __ ]
so I'm like hey man how are you I sort
of stepped around him and then when I
went to look into the bathroom which I
did for [ __ ] two seconds you know
trying to feel the backside pressure by
the way you know like when a quarterback
doesn't feel the rush you know trying to
feel that [ __ ] axe I was Bobby to go
to my back I look into the bathroom and
all along the bathtub this guy had
knee-high dress socks drying on that
then I was just like I was just like I'm
in a [ __ ] see you later and I did I
give us see that walk racing that that
was a big fat in the 70s I did that
right out of that [ __ ] house and I
told a guy I go Jesus Christ I can see
why this has been on the market for so
[ __ ] long how the [ __ ] he's supposed
to sell it when the goddamn creep Kippur
Keepers creep keeper the Crypt Keeper
I like verbally dyslexic forget about
trying to read um it's sitting up there
I didn't dare look you know when I was
standing in I said all this [ __ ] and all
those old houses you can hear everything
when you're outside I was standing right
underneath the [ __ ] bedroom window
and I didn't dare look up there cuz I
had a feeling who's gonna be standing in
the window staring at me I was gonna
have [ __ ] nightmares and and I just I
just five [ __ ] left I left
and I have this creepy [ __ ] feeling
that because I went into that house I
got exposed to something and at some
point today my home phone which I never
use so it never [ __ ] rings is going
to ring and I'm gonna pick it up and
it's going to be that guy's voice going
seven days and then I gotta somehow
expose somebody I know to it so I don't
[ __ ] die having said that it was a
great house that had a lot of potential
oh my god
Jesus Christ that that house needed a
giant [ __ ] hug needed to get that guy
out of it and deceit you needed to buy
all the sage in the state of California
and [ __ ] set it on fire in it in one
thing either happens either burns out
all the spirits or it burns down the
house and you start over again I haven't
said that though despite how [ __ ]
creepy it was the fact that it had a
room over a garage that's that's the
only way I would ever leave this house
is if I could find a [ __ ] house you
know I don't know I got to get out of
this [ __ ] state I got to get out of
this [ __ ] city it's so [ __ ] stupid
every [ __ ] house I don't care how
nice it is you can literally stick your
hand out the window and before your hand
completely extends you can touch your
neighbor's house it's unbelievable it's
like where the [ __ ] do you have to go
there's just too many [ __ ] people um
anyways plowing ahead here try to some
reads for this week let's do some rates
what do we got here I got a little more
advertising to go who the [ __ ] wants
listen me read out loud anymore let's uh
let's read some of the some of the
questions for the week I'll read two of
these in the last two advertisings how
about that all right and then I'll read
the rest of the questions all right
Polish invention hey Bill I saw this on
reddit kind of [ __ ] two people go to
Reddit by the way how do you even figure
out what's going on it looks like
computer code people always tell me you
got to go on reddit it's like I content
looks like the [ __ ] Declaration of
Independence I'm not reading all that
[ __ ] I saw this on reddit it was a
machine made by some polish guy to cut
wood
does knowing its polish make you double
guess yourself double guess yourself as
to whether or not it's good invention
because of polish jokes double guess
yourself and this guy's making fun of
Polish people I definitely did I'm at
the point where I have no idea your
thoughts well I don't know how to clegg
I go back here to click the link I can
tell you this we no I don't think we
need any better way to cut down [ __ ]
trees do you ever see that [ __ ]
invention it looks like a [ __ ]
bulldozer without without the bulldozer
front end and the thing just reaches out
grabs the tree rips it out of the ground
turns it [ __ ] horizontal and goes
right up one side were down the other
and completely strips it down and it
does this within like [ __ ] I don't
know it within 10 seconds and literally
one man in that machine can do the work
of like an army of Lumberjacks for a
year it's uh it's terrifying when I saw
it to be honest with you
you know as I talk about looking at a
house that I don't need and then redoing
it what are you gonna redo it bill
what do you redo it with the [ __ ]
wood that that machine cut down alright
let me see if I can find the alright
here's the link let me look at this
thing
alright
ow God well you know what I know you're
making fun of Polish people this is just
some guy in his backyard came up with
this I bet you couldn't come up with
this [ __ ] thing and to be honest with
you I just had to cut up my Christmas
tree for this year sorry I'm sure that
was really annoying to listen to um
that's great let's see what people say
underneath this is way better than the
thousand degree knife videos I am
irrationally angry at the completely
different sizes of cuts of the second
log short on firewood we specialize in
short firewood I don't even know what
this guy put on there but he basically
he hooked it up to his uh what's that
thing between the transmission and the
differential past the universal joint
I'm going [ __ ] blank here he
basically just hooked that up to that
and he's using the engine turning of the
engine what why do people just hate on
everybody out there I'm good for him
I don't [ __ ] was I supposed to trash
Polish people
I like Polish people I like their food
and I don't know I mean I'm sure they've
made movies about it but not here in the
United States because we're so focused
on our own [ __ ] point of view like
most countries but Poland I'm fascinated
with because during World War two they
were sandwiched between two of the
biggest mad men of all time Adolf Hitler
and Joseph Stalin they were stuck in
between the two of them the most
precarious [ __ ] position of any
country that I can ever [ __ ] think of
and they somehow [ __ ] survived so I
don't think they're dumb then I look
forward someday to going there and
seeing that beautiful country eating
their food and doing a [ __ ] show whoa
having a couple of [ __ ] beers all
right from Turkey I'm sick of being
called a delusional conspiracy theorist
by my family in my leg
he said I live in the Republic of Turkey
maybe you've heard that there was a coup
here last year yes I did
I put it in quotation because it was the
most pathetic attempt in Turkish history
so it didn't go down like the Ukraine
long conspiracy short your guys were
losing control of our guys whom they
installed here to have a nice little
proxy to the lovesy to the lovely oil
desert downtown deserts downtown I
already love how this person is thinking
so they try to pull the carpet from
under our guys because God knows they
can't pass aggression wars in your
Congress anymore since you American
citizens are woke as [ __ ] now thankfully
I guess we're not because I don't know
what any of this means by the way you
don't write like you're from Turkey like
this is your second language you're
using like really high-level slang for
someone who lives on the other side of
the world anyways this pathetic coup
attempt created a lot of turmoil here I
mean it would be less destructive if it
succeeded because now through their
paranoia they are going full apeshit
which turns Turkey to a bitter sweet
heaven for a conspiracy theorist like
myself with all the stuff going on all
right well there's no [ __ ] way I'm
reading your name so you don't end up in
a jail if you actually are from Turkey I
can deal with my family's indifference
to all this and my friends now most
likely our most liked me regarding these
subjects but the fact that my girl
stonewalls me goes yeah doll okay really
annoys me down deep of course it does
anytime you're passionate about an
opinion and somebody just goes oh really
okay sweetheart forget about it so if
it's a woman that you have feelings for
she is a totally dope chick in every
other aspect dude you're not from Turkey
you're not from Turkey but I'll continue
with this fun to hang out hates the
movies and music I hate has c-cup fun
pillows that were sculpted by God
himself from my palms but I can't help
lose respect for her when it comes to
her not giving a single [ __ ]
politics and stuff she's convinced she
doesn't get affected by them for some
reason and it doesn't matter I'm curious
how you dealt with this feeling also I'm
very interested in how you reach
information about the world and what
news outlets you trust from Turkey with
love to you and Nia all right well let's
say you're from Turkey very impressive
your English and your slang you're
actually better at my language than I am
all right here's what you have to
understand as a conspiracy theorist is
that you're you're really you're a lot
to deal with and you really wear people
out this is what I learned when I went
down the rabbit hole which I got out of
a good 2-3 years ago is that as much as
you don't trust what the [ __ ] people are
telling you which is really common sense
and I'm not saying there's a bunch of
[ __ ] crazy people living under a
mountain pulling the strings but what
I'm saying is that everybody is spinning
the [ __ ] because everybody has their own
agenda so you can't you don't like if
you just if you [ __ ] showed up to a
two car accident okay both people are
going to spin it in a way even if one
person was a hundred percent right
they're still going to spin it so
there's no [ __ ] way that you know
they can be perceived they're going to
spin it just because the other person is
spin it just to offset their spinning up
it's like listening to that whole
[ __ ] Russia tapped into a you know
hacked into our [ __ ] you're going to
listen to the Democrats spinning it the
Republicans spinning it the CIA spinning
it and then [ __ ] Russia their spin on
it so will at the end of it who the [ __ ]
knows what happened I'll I just love how
our country is acting like we don't spy
on Russia and we don't try to influence
elections around the [ __ ] world and
we haven't placed people in power taking
people out and all of that's [ __ ]
hilarious
all of a sudden happens to us and it's a
big goddamn tragedy so I would say
respect the fact that she's not into
politics I'm envious of people that can
then you know I kind of did that after a
while like after a while it's just like
you scream
into a tornado alright it's way bigger
than you are there are people out there
that have the ability and the influence
to [ __ ] I guess turn [ __ ] around but
I'm not that guy I'm just some [ __ ]
guy ruining your beer at a bar by
bringing all my delusional paranoid
[ __ ] thoughts whether I'm right or
not which I was probably right on a few
things like Mel Gibson in that movie
where he drove the taxicab I was
probably right about a few [ __ ]
things but I don't know what they are so
all you're doing is just annoying the
[ __ ] out of people and I have to be
honest with you if your girl actually
loves you and she's to the point of
responding of yeah dull okay I think
you've probably worn her down I bet she
didn't say that in the beginning she
probably listened to it and you promptly
freaked her out and you don't have a
solution you're just saying all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's just going to ruin
her day so maybe that's her defense
mechanism and I'm what I'm doing is I'm
not being it I'm not going dr. Phil here
and just siding with the woman because I
don't have a female audience unlike that
[ __ ] dishonest [ __ ] right you need to
do what she says when you look ladies
when you look at dr. Phil when you
honestly look at that man do you see
somebody do you honestly do not see how
volatile a human being that guy is can
you just imagine living with that man
when he loses his [ __ ] just imagine that
semi-bald head and face just beat red
screaming at you his spittle getting
caught in his moustache just imagine
that and he's a big man - okay I'm
telling you I know he's got that
Southern drawl and you just think
everybody's a [ __ ] gentleman you know
the way women love a foreign [ __ ] axe
I guess guys like it - I don't know I I
don't what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
anyways let's get back to this guy um to
lose respect for the fact that
somebody's not into what the [ __ ] you're
into is
that's a sign you know it'd be one thing
if she just didn't give a [ __ ] about me
I don't know I I'd have to know who the
[ __ ] she was that could just be a
defense mechanism where it's just like
whatever it doesn't affect my life you
know I've done that with global warming
and all of that type of [ __ ] I've just
started to block it out because there's
nothing I can do to get people to I
don't and I don't even know what the
Sundering what the [ __ ] solution is
the only solution I have is to [ __ ]
exterminate
most of us 90% of us and then just
[ __ ] everybody sits in a ball in
hopes that everything that we've put
into the earth and into the air kind of
goes away after a while that that's the
only solution I have which I don't think
that that's going to work so um I don't
know I just you know I try to [ __ ] do
whatever the [ __ ] I can do which is you
know I don't know see dude this is why
people don't like could see you
literally bringing this up his Brent
brought me to a dark [ __ ] place and
your email alone just told me that just
got me to say that we need to
exterminate 90% of the people on the
[ __ ] planet how it's saying is that
how you gonna do that bill you gonna do
that to babies too or you're not going
to do babies but you're gonna kill all
those [ __ ] parents and then what you
can have the most giant [ __ ] nursery
like it all it all unravels the whole
[ __ ] thing that's why I kind of
stopped doing the conspiracy theory
thing even though I still throw it out
there because it's fun and I and I also
don't believe a [ __ ] word anybody's
telling me when it comes to that [ __ ]
you know one on one you know if i sat
down with somebody and it's not cameras
around then I could feel like they can
really be honest with me but the second
you're on TV you know it's only so
honest you could be so I don't know III
would probably guess that on some level
you're a lot to be around during certain
news stories and I think you should
lighten up a little bit take your
girlfriend now go get a [ __ ] ice
cream and enjoy the fact that someone is
beautiful as you're saying is she is
actually can tolerate you and your your
[ __ ] theories
all right having said that if I ever go
to Turkey I'll definitely have a beer
with you and I'll [ __ ] up I'll go
[ __ ] toe for toe with you Helen
conspiracy theories all right and thank
you for listening to the podcast okay
girlfriend was unwillingly married what
all right dear Billy psycho tits I don't
know what that means but I like that one
I'm 25 years old and finally found out
the girl of my dreams and finally found
the girl of my dreams well good for you
dude you found her pretty young she's 23
years old smile super attractive and we
have been in a relationship for the last
nine months I don't even have the urge
to go to bars and sleep with women
anymore
she asked me all types of screwed up
it's amazing my family loves her
especially my father who never gives a
[ __ ] about my relationships
she's from Yemen and his Muslim and
although she has she doesn't really
follow the religion she is forced she's
forced to by her parents that being said
one weekend last month she told me her
sister was having an arranged marriage
and she was headed to the wedding I did
not hear from her for three days she
finally contacted oh no she finally
contacted me back after I constantly
reached out to her and she told me we
had to talk Oh No
once we met up she told me she was
unwillingly married off to a man from
Yemen and that she had no idea this was
going to happen oh my god is this real
this is a lifetime script she told me
that since her parents signed the
marriage documents she really had no
choice in a religion in God's eyes she
was she's married she made it clear that
she was in love with me and that she
wanted to be with me is that [ __ ]
chick who punches herself in the chest
gonna start singing at this point what's
her name she does the casino gigs she's
from Canada
she sang the Titanic song right
Leonardo DiCaprio on the front of the
ship
whatever the [ __ ] song no that's
that's in the arms of the angel
that's about rescue dogs what [ __ ]
song oh yeah near fall
well uh how much does she [ __ ] hate
that song having to sing that to a bunch
of casino dopes sitting there in
flip-flops getting teared up you know
anyways she made it clear with me she
made it clear that she was in love with
me and that she wanted me to be with me
only she told me she pleaded with her
parents but they wouldn't budge we then
came up with the date that if her
parents still wouldn't budge she would
just move in with me out of her parents
home and we would figure it out together
during the during the week after text
messages turned to about three message a
day and I did not get to see her at all
I think this you know even if you made
this up this is an incredible story I
think got a message from her best friend
and she told me that her that my
girlfriend was lying to me oh now now
who do you believe she told me that my
girl had been engaged since she was 16
years old her new husband is forcing
himself to try to [ __ ] her and she is
threatening her in and is threatening
her with violence alright dude this is
going outside the realm of my silly
little podcast here as well as taking
her taking her away her phone she does
make it clear that my girl does love me
with all her heart but will never leave
due to her parents disowning or if she
decides to leave this marriage what the
[ __ ] what period the period [ __ ] period
I immediately contact my girl and she
admits to everything she told me she
knew about the wedding beforehand and
doesn't think she could do that to her
family he's trying to have sex with her
but she cries and then he just stops oh
boy well you know what can I commend
that other guy you know any guy who can
plow through a woman crying
that's just a [ __ ] animal that needs
to be shot in the back of the [ __ ]
head so this guy is actually not a bad
guy I don't think he's just wrapped up
in the [ __ ] custom Jesus Christ gotta
love religion everybody I have no idea
what to do she won't go against her
parents but she loves me and she's just
given up she was such a strong and tough
person now she's just going with the
unwilling maybe she should just keep
crying
and that guy's decent enough - dude dude
- just be a guy you know [ __ ] this hurt
Aaron told me she's depressed and
doesn't have the fight nur currently
she's blocked by friends our mutual
friends and our family are from social
media my family and friends have been
calming me down this guy who thinks he
owns my girl would get American History
X curb stomp if I find out he lays a
hand on her alright this stop being
funny like at least nine paragraphs ago
like I usually have like light-hearted
funny [ __ ] here but that might also
complicate things for her yeah if you
murdered the guy absolutely anyways I
love your podcast don't stop what you're
doing - go [ __ ] yourself I don't believe
that I don't believe that story
I'm not saying [ __ ] like that doesn't
happen but I don't believe that someone
would write this level of serious [ __ ]
into me yeah I don't that that got a
little too [ __ ] sensational for me
not saying that [ __ ] like that doesn't
happen but you know if that actually is
true I don't know why you're running to
this podcast I think at that point you
need to write - uh I'm gonna say is
wrong as it Neum Lisa my Liam Neeson
that [ __ ] guy
you need you need to write to that guy
and find out who wrote the scripts in
the words that he said and then find out
what they base that off of and gradually
go back and find whoever the [ __ ] Liam
Neeson named Liam is pretending to
[ __ ] be I should know who that guys
[ __ ] name is right considering I act
every once in a while I should know who
one of the best guys out there Liam
Neeson Oh Liam Neeson
he's born in 1952 Jesus Christ that
guy's like 60 63 [ __ ] years old and I
still wouldn't [ __ ] with them not even
remotely you know certain actors that
play a character and you're like yeah
he's just pretend to be a tough guy then
there's other people were you just like
you know you know I think that guy could
really beat the [ __ ] out of me you know
you just saw on the ground when is this
scene and Liam
all right Bank friends virgin ex dear
straw Billy pubes forever uh a month
back I recently acquired a recently
acquired friend was at my house and
unbeknownst to me his girlfriend at the
time was my next-door neighbor all right
I was just thinking about the Beatles I
got to strike that maybe this is a month
back hey recently no Jesus Christ you
know I I forgot I gotta read those all
the to advertisings I know you guys like
what the [ __ ] I know just let me just
knock these out really quickly can I
just do this here alright I did me
undies oh wait a minute do I only have
one left
oh what a bonus I got one left
stamps.com it's an easy one alright ah
our old friend stamps com1 great
resolution you can make for the new year
maximize every minute and every dollar
for your small business fat and stop
drinking in front of your children think
about how much time you've wasted going
to the post office driving there finding
parking fighting old ladies just use
what you already have your computer and
printer to get official us I think they
missed a paragraph their official u.s.
postage for any letter a package then
the mailman picks it up though I'm
missing a paragraph here all the
[ __ ] you go through going to the
post office driving there finding
parking [ __ ] smelly old people crazy
people going up there and having the
wrong envelope being told that you have
to go back to the end of the line
thinking you're next and then [ __ ]
the person puts the sign up next window
please and there's no windows open right
imagine if you could do everything you
can do with the post office right at
home well you can do that with
stamps.com ah you like that a rift
whole thing just use what you already
have your computer and printer to get
official US postage for any letter a
package then the mailman picks it up as
simple as that but stamps calm
everything you could do with the
post-office you do right from your own
desk and at the fraction of the cost of
one of those expensive postage meters I
use stamps comm whenever I send out my
posters when I'm whoring myself out at
the end of my show to make a few more
bucks it's so convenient right now sign
up for stamps comm use my code bar for
this special offer for week trial plus
$110 bonus offer including postage and a
digital scale don't wait go to Stan's
calm before you do anything else click
on the microphone stop the homepage and
type in bur that stamps comm enter ber
stands calm never go to the post office
again by the way there's still a few
tickets left for the Patrice O'Neal
comedy benefit February 21st New York
City Center don't miss up don't [ __ ]
miss out we got a special guest all
right here we go
banged friends virgin ex all right let's
start again
dear strawberry Billy pubes forever
straw Billy pubes forever there we go a
month back a reason recently acquired
friend was at my house and unbeknownst
to me his girlfriend at the time was my
next-door neighbor a few weeks later
they had broken up because she wasn't
putting out apparently they had dated
for three months and he couldn't take it
anymore
here's the thing oh Jesus one thing led
to another next thing you know long
story short a week ago I was drunk with
a different buddy one thing led to
another sorry and we decided it would be
funny to invite her and her roommates
over to play board games
I was pretty buzzed and had all the
confidence in the world I walked over to
a house and it just so happens she was
the only one home though Jesus she
invited me in since like some red Shoe
Diaries that's really happened she
invited me in for some cookies her
sorority maid one thing led to another
there we go
and we ended up [ __ ] one thing led to
another the classic phrase she was
obviously inexperienced so it was
nothing to write home about this
normally wouldn't be a problem
except she's my next-door neighbor so
naturally I have repeated the process
about a dozen times my question is
should I tell my friend normally I
wouldn't say anything but I think I'm
falling for this girl he's been kind of
distant lately so he might have some
suspicions thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
please come to San Diego and congrats on
the baby Jesus is there anything funnier
than a young man with a dick you know
Jesus Christ dude uncle you think he's
getting suspicious she lives next door
you've been over there 12 times yeah
he's gonna figure it out um well look
you know he broke up with her he was
only there with her for three months how
well did you how well duh
how much Alf are you great friends with
this person yeah it gets messy against
me I don't know what you're asking me
here you know it's a [ __ ] great story
other than it used to be your friend's
girlfriend but he [ __ ] tapped out
maybe that's what you should say to him
when he calls you on it he'd just been
he shouldn't tapped out man should have
kept mining for gold is golden in their
heels um
I don't know the fact that you've been
with this girl for 12 times you think
you're falling for her I don't think
you're falling for I think you love the
convenience of it if I had to guess you
really didn't write too deeply about
your [ __ ] about your [ __ ] feelings
for this girl I think you went further
into the fact that how you [ __ ]
nailed this girl in your your friend
didn't so I don't know if you're really
not into this girl I would just pull the
[ __ ] plug and I would never bring it
up and I'd wait - that guy is a couple
of Miller High Life sin to him and at
that point I would stay out of his
wheelhouse because he might [ __ ]
sucker puncher cuz you know what
happened all right
What did he say bang friend's
ex-girlfriend so he didn't say he
accidentally did it so yeah well you
know you know what you were doing and
you did it and now that's that's that's
the world you created it in you're
living in it so I don't know what to
tell you
um other than if you're not really
falling for this girl I would stop
[ __ ] her day you go I don't care how
good the cookies are all right Colin
girlfriend a [ __ ] hey Bill Hope
fatherhood is treating you well if it
finally happened has not happened yet
recently my girlfriend was being very
unreasonable and running her mouth about
something and I said she was being a
[ __ ] didn't call her a [ __ ] rather
acting like one you know what there is a
loophole there there is a loophole there
but when he dropped the c-word it's it's
very difficult like I've never called my
wife a [ __ ] ever I've never done the
entire time a bit I never called it that
once one time I did say that she was
acting like one and she brought that up
for like [ __ ] three years because she
knew how important it was to me to never
call her that
and she [ __ ] we got into a fight and
then she pushed my buttons trying to get
me [ __ ] more and more mad because
that's what they do and they're not
doing it maliciously that's how they
fight most of them where guys go what
you [ __ ] you say then you start [ __ ]
fist fighting women usually don't get to
that level so they're fist fighting is
they they've already broken you down
psyche psychologically and they just try
to make you as mad as they can and if
you're with a cool woman they'll they'll
take responsibility for that and they'll
eventually forgive you so anyways all
right so you said that she was acting
like one okay since then she's had her
panties in a twist and thinks I owe her
an apology I haven't given her one my
thoughts are that if anyone male or
female is acting like a [ __ ] I can call
him a [ __ ] what she thought thoughts on
wimp calling women a [ __ ] and have you
gotten into trouble for calling a woman
a [ __ ] I've never done that to a woman
that I've dated have I ever called a
woman a [ __ ] you know it's funny as much
as I use that word I don't think I've
ever done that
now I don't do the name-calling thing as
angry as I am if I ever done that
I definitely again [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
psycho I've done that but I don't I
don't do the I don't do the [ __ ] the
those classics I don't I don't I don't
break out the classics I don't say [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't say anything that um yeah I
don't I just don't I saw I saw that
early on in my life that that doesn't
work and I saw what it does to a
relationship I just saw it you know I
had a paper route when I was a kid so
you know you get to step into a lot of
people's homes and watch a little movie
trailer and a lot of times you're
walking up to the house and you can hear
the the director's cut of what's going
on before you went in there you know so
I saw a lot of that you know being from
Massachusetts there was a lot of
hotheads
and I don't know as much as a dick as I
am I've never done that and I can tell
you that it gets you nowhere so and the
thing the stubborn thing that you're
doing right now that you're not
apologizing for it is going to cause her
to dig her heels in and what you're
doing is you're creating this toxic
[ __ ] cesspool in your relationship
okay
you could have set a bunch of other
words and you went to DEFCON five or
whatever the [ __ ] is it one is one the
worst there was five the worst whatever
the worst one you went nuclear honor I
think he should apologize and just say
for the record I didn't say you were a
[ __ ] I respect you enough to not call
you a [ __ ] I just said you were acting
like what okay I won't do that in the
future I was wrong I don't even don't
even defend you just say I apologize for
what I said I shouldn't have said it
just just apologize all right and
there'll be some residual [ __ ] but I can
tell you right this right now if you're
gonna make a relationship work
when you're in the wrong you have to
apologize you have to do that because if
you don't apologize if you always get
your [ __ ] back up if you fight them
every [ __ ] step of the way then you
stop being a person to them you're just
this thing you're just this loud
annoying [ __ ] thing okay but if you
say you're sorry if you ever if you say
like you know what you're right and bla
bla bla bla bla the times when you
actually are defending your position you
have clout because you've admitted that
you were wrong when you were wrong so
there you go now I'm not saying she
wasn't being a [ __ ] okay now that's the
type of thing if you want to say that
that's what you say when you got you one
[ __ ] buddy who for the most part can
keep his [ __ ] mouth shut but even
then you can't depend on that okay if
you're ever going to call your woman a
[ __ ] you [ __ ] do it you go for a
drive and you do it in your car by
yourself and you yell everything that
you want to yell because she's not
listening to you you make all your
[ __ ] points you [ __ ] crush it you
give you a closing argument to the
invisible jury inside your car and then
in the end you know and if you actually
stop for a second and listen to me you
don't have stand that but you can't
because you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ] right
and then you look over you know at the
other person sitting there at the red
light with you and if it's another guy
if it's me I'm gonna laugh you know not
at you but I'm gonna laugh knowing what
the [ __ ] you're doing
and if it's a woman she's probably gonna
laugh knowing what the [ __ ] you're doing
or if she's a [ __ ] she's gonna [ __ ]
squint her eyes at her and be more of a
[ __ ] ah there you go so um yeah I do not
nor what'd I ever do that I would to the
total to my wife I would never [ __ ]
do that I wouldn't do that to any woman
that I was in business with I wouldn't
do that with any [ __ ] poor I wouldn't
do that in general but generally
speaking when I talk about people
I kind of just call men [ __ ]
I think it's funny to call a man a [ __ ]
to call a woman a [ __ ] is it's just not
funny calling a guy a [ __ ] is [ __ ]
hilarious
and I stand by that all right not saying
that this nut cuts God knows that word
exists for [ __ ] reason but it's just
too [ __ ] mean and I'm telling you you
lose you lose in the end because you
know they could just make your life
miserable in every court of law
generally speaking out there is going to
side with them and next thing you know
you will never play drums again because
she's going to take them from you all
right not the [ __ ] baby okay that's
the podcast for this week god bless you
all right you [ __ ] [ __ ] go [ __ ]
yourselves and I will check in on you on
Thursday